Joe do you know that they didn't have
clocks back then there was no clock
could measure they had sunds but what
are you going to do at night was the
first clock so Galo tried to invent the
first clock it was actually part of a
precursor to the Nobel Prize it was
something called the longitude prize
they offered a prize I don't know if
you've ever done any boating or whatever
but when you're out on the ocean it's
extremely hard to determine what your
longitude is it's easy to find your
latitude you just look for Polaris the
North Star you measure your elevation
and that's going to complement where you
are latitudinally on the on the um axis
going from South Pole to North Pole on
the Earth but it was impossible to tell
where you are east to west from the
prime meridian unless you had a Accurate
Way of measuring time so Galileo um was
was one of the first people to try to
compete to win this prize which was
worth you know like a million dollars
back then in those days and he uh tried
a couple different ways to invent time
pieces but the one that he tried to
settle on was this use of the planet
Jupiter's moons